In China, Beijing is demanding the immediate release of a key executive...
...of telecom giant Huawei Technologies,...
...whose arrest in Canada could threaten the recent truce...
...in the trade war between the United States and China.
In Iran, a Sunni jihadist group is claiming responsibility...
...for a suicide car bombing that struck a police headquarters...
...in Chabahar on Thursday,...
...killing at least two police officers and wounding 42 other people.
As Yemen borders on the brink of famine,...
...the executive director for the United Nations' World Food Programme...
...said the situation is worsening and agencies need to help assist the population.
In France, in the midst of violent yellow vest protests...
...fighting against a hike in fuel taxes,...
...leaders of France's opposition conservatives are calling for President Macron...
...to declare a state of emergency.
Finally from Australia, a court overturns the conviction...
...of the world's most senior Catholic cleric...
...who was charged with concealing child sex abuse.